would like to see tougher sanctions and
i'd like that threat to be very real
because
let's see this for what it is it's
russian aggression so i won't see the
government go further on sanctions but i
will say this russia wants to see
our allies divided it wants to see
division in the united kingdom and we
are not going to divide and therefore we
support the government in what it's
doing we support our allies and the
sovereignty of ukraine but yes those
sanctions should go further
ben wallace commented at the weekend
that there was a whiff of munich about
the situation in ukraine and was
apparently referring to the futility of
western diplomatic efforts on this is
the strategy
of the western leaders failing to putin
a lot has been read into the comments of
the defense secretary this weekend i
think every effort should be made to try
and ensure there's a peaceful
way out of this but this is russian
aggression and we need to stand together
and the defense secretary has been very
open and collaborative in his dealings
with us on a cross-party basis
if there is an invasion this week as
predicted by the u.s would you call for
parliament to be recalled i think it's
very important that parliament is
recalled if there is an invasion
i'm sure the government would do that
anyway because we must have a swift and
strong response a united response to the
united kingdom united response with our
allies so yes parliament should be
recalled in those circumstances
it's been reported that the police have
launched an investigation into online
threats made against you have you
received death threats since the prime
minister's false claim about savile
the prime minister knew what he was
doing when he
introduced that slur uh the other day
but this is not about me
you know there are threats to too many
politicians particularly women actually
we've all got a duty to bring that level
down and to return to the politics where
we have strong debate um strong
arguments but it's rational it's honest
and it's done with integrity do you
believe the prime minister is directly
responsible for those threats because of
his remarks about savile well the prime
minister knew exactly what he was doing
and words have consequences but i do not
want to turn this into an issue about
myself because very many politicians
receive abuse
and threats
women much more than men in terms of
politics we all on a cross-party basis
have a duty to de-escalate these issues
and to conduct our politics properly in
a rational and proper way